а тієї ж осені прийшла
мисад і я ж на іклів
за тумани ловися голубу і ронила всертий
та жур-бу
Ну що там не скажемо
розкажи інформативно тиша
а ти щоб я заводжу це хлопцями
дівчатам роботу
а я до будинку вже
[музика]
станемо годиною українці постригає вже ті
кого тенденцію ще раніше
150 200 осі за раз 500-600 з чим
цепов'язаний від своєї у нас пофарбувалася
система вигляду чеки з ін причини
[оплески]
[музика]
сказати вічка з чим би ви могли зараз
на Росії вилучаю
Господи Давайте
[музика]
собакою щоб тебе махала
Опа тріпалий заходить
[музика]
[оплески]
ось няньку я за порожніми Всі хочуть трохи
одна і далека Ну механіка є
механіками змінюється ще 280 його не такі
на роботі У мене акумулятори піднімали
я джодира ми їх стягнув до нас утрил
хочемо за нею Каті 93 все забрала я їм
згадаю
[сміх]
[музика]
Зеленський для вас
17 числа
унітаз Ти йти поруч у кульках
[музика]
рашки кінець Як ти ставишся до того що
Краснодар стане народною республікою
приєднатися до України
так
чи ні
Україна надала їжа Ну в планах
є це буде десь 2024 року.
пару років але Краснодар теж був у списках
Я бачив я ми будемо ми будемо українцями
тобто в Україні жити та в Україні але
ви будете європейцями, бо
українці це європеєць
на вигляд можна буде їздити до Європи дуже
дешеві квитки та працювати та відпочивати
подорожувати все буде зручно тепер
Москву Вже до Москви Китай забирає
а тобто Росія взагалі не буде так
слово такого не буде у 2025 році слово
Росія не існуватиме
[музика]
Слава Україні Слава Наті та російських
до будинку
Я таки думаю що
прогладиться бо пакета я вже зайшов чим
вже фарбована сказав
[музика]
жити Артик і мотивація то я сильно
філософія психологія найголовніша
завершується людьми і кричить що ви
ляже гірки
все красень
[музика]